society says that women can move
seductively it is sexy it is looked at
as beautiful when a man does it it's
looked at a little effeminate gyrating I
[Music]
think there are varying degrees of sex
work I think that there is a spectrum
and I think that as a stripper I was on
the spectrum of being a sex worker
I wouldn't necessarily have called
myself a sex worker in the past because
I didn't have enough education on what a
sex worker was and I also feel like I've
not earned the right to call myself a
full-service sex worker so that's why I
just prefer sex worker because there was
a higher degree of sex work above
stripping I think I don't find myself to
be a sex worker I find myself to be
creative when I'm on stage performing
even though it's sexual you're creating
a whole Act I agree with you know that
it is an art form and that you are
creating you know a whole persona
whether it's you know firing actor or
your compact cowboy something like that
but still in the sex industry and you
know you sexy ass dude you know don't
try to deny it and you out there being
sexy for the ladies and that's how
they're to see you because you know it's
it's XXL's for me a lot goes into what I
do at work the way that I put myself
together where I present myself the way
that I you know do hair and makeup and
glam and outfits and all that kind of
stuff goes into it and I think that goes
more into entertainment then it would
sex work but don't you think that like
when you're out there that the majority
of your client tells men right yeah
they're out there because you know they
sighs about being with you specifically
you know what I mean so I think that
should be considered a sex worker
because that's that's what your
clientele is thinking when they see you
well that would be the same way that
they see Angelina Jolie as well though
they go see her movies because she is a
great actress but she's also an
extremely beautiful woman yeah so a male
can go and watch her movies and say it's
God I wish you know I was married to ng
Lena Jolie but she is a bona fide movie
star Magic Mike and Chippendales are two
most iconic figures for male stripping
and I don't think they misrepresent male
stripping off anything I think they're
pretty on point because I actually
started dancing because I watched Magic
Mike yeah that's what got me thinking
like I could do this yeah I can actually
I want to be a male stripper and since
I've started dancing it it is very
similar to the movie you know there's
you get the review you get the house
parties and that's pretty much it's cut
and dry well we got a lot of people that
think that we gave to a lot of times I
get women all the time saying are you
gay or you're dancing gay I have nothing
against gay people but where's that
media come from the like you know where
they get the idea society says that
women can move seductively it is sexy it
is looked at as beautiful when a man
does it this looks better little
effeminate gyrating
good most men do not have that kind of
coordination in rhythm okay it's wild
because customers will talk to me or
talk to you know dancers for a little
bit and then they'll be like wow you're
you're kind of smart like they're
surprised they say that to us too they
don't think we're smart at all yeah just
a bit less doing a body that's all they
think we are doing jokes that I see all
the time is that we have we are
supporting our drug habits and our
children and like we're just turning
tricks all the time yes some of those
things are true but that's not all it is
and then like on Family Guy's it Family
Guy or American Dad where they're
basically like strippers have no souls
and I'm actually had people say that to
me because they're learning it on TV and
I like told her very kindly like don't
ever say that to someone ever again you
learned the wrong information that is
not how we are for example the DJ's that
that we have sometimes they're like
really touchy with the girls and if
you're not the type of girl that likes
to get touched then you tell them no
like they won't put you on stage and
they will skip you and they will put
girls ahead of you so I see that you're
gonna really tip them and I tend to like
clip them a lot yeah and I always I have
always like kind of bumped heads with
some of the DJs because of that I mean
it's wrong and then sometimes like the
customers are really touching and it's
kind of like you know I've never
personally had that experience customers
they can get drunk but you know I've
never had anything outlandishly
disrespectful happening at work I've
been like recognized by people at the
mall and stuff and I've had really nasty
things that simmer so would you say
outside work
you get harassed more than inside work
if somebody yeah cuz I mean I'm free
game at the mall I'm shopping I'm on my
phone and I just hear somebody down the
hall like screaming you know you you
strip you know they call me the b-word
like what's this person that's turning
around and he was like when you in the
club you act like you don't know me
and answer me don't see me you think
you're too good and stuff like that like
I've been cursed out miles parties all
kind of stuff cause that does happen
there's a difference between you know
male stripping and female stripping
because you got bouncers you got
security you got like you know your
employer male stripping is you know
independent contracting so when we show
up to a party it's usually house parties
it's the majority of our work you know
there are reviews but you're only there
for what like one to two hours at a club
and we're men it's just like a classic
case you know I don't know since way
back when since the beginning of time
that woman have always been you know
victimized and sexually harassed and
it's kind of hard to sexually harass a
man I feel like I've had people punch me
when I was on save I just have people
like try to finger me and doing a lap
dance I've had everything people untie
your bikini people judge your bank
everything touching your face is gross
link but I think you should expect
somewhat of link some sexual harassment
from a situation that that sexually
charged especially if you add alcohol to
it sometimes I like the sexual
harassment I'm not saying we should like
it or you should have to like it but you
should kind of expect it sometimes or
like be prepared for it at least
[Music]
I am a dad of three kids when they come
see me in Cali I don't dance I shove it
to the side for three or four weeks but
in the end of the day it's important
that I maintain a single life so I can
make the utmost money for them and being
single is better because if I have a
woman she's gonna tell me well I don't
want you to go out this then tonight I
want you to perform tonight and stuff
like that it's gonna hurt my my stuff I
was with someone for five years and it
was all fine until one day he just
wasn't okay with it anymore and started
like slut-shaming me after five years
but the dude I'm with now just doesn't
really like not that he doesn't pay
attention to it but he doesn't like come
into the club he doesn't like really
have to see what I you know I don't know
I guess it would bum him out if he saw
like the amount of flirting but it's
different flirting that I would how I
would flirt with him but it's weird
because people change like they think
that they're fine with it or they
pretend like they're fine with it and
they're really not for me it's not that
I can't find someone that will accept me
I wouldn't want to date anyone when like
while I'm stripping because I mean the
things that we have to do it's like
we're acting like if we're interested in
like the customers or you know flirting
I feel like in a way that's to me I'm
not saying for everyone to me that's
like cheating like I can't I can't and
then when they ask you like do you have
a boyfriend and then if I say yeah then
it's kind of like that's already kind of
like a deal-breaker
you know
[Music]
in in my 10 years of dancing I had one
guy like come in and like try to
actively pursue me so it was like every
shift he was coming in and he wasn't
totally haggard so you know after a
while I was like all right I'll go on a
few dates with you but you know he
turned out to be a total [ __ ] weirdo
so you know I didn't have to last anyway
I performed in New York City in Webster
Hall and I met my ex right there oh it
was a blessing because I have three
beautiful kids and you know we're still
friends and it's cool you know saying
because I did meet a good person at the
time sometimes you meet someone just
like you would out at the nightclub or
the bar and you're like yeah let's go
home and do stuff together I mean yeah
I'm a person I'm attracted to other
people and sometimes you know it just
works out
I didn't have like the greatest like
upbringing my mom was pretty terrible to
me my everybody was like you know so I
grew up kind of like Lola oh my gosh to
even think about like my daughter I feel
like I'm there like I feel like she can
do so much more than dancing know what
I'm doing I'm not saying that stripping
is bad because it pays my bills and
there's beautiful woman that to me and
they're there because they're single
moms but I just feel like my daughter
would she there's something so much
better than she can do than this I mean
I didn't have a bad childhood and I
ended up in something like this I was
actually very well supported in my
entire life as a child and given all and
every opportunity and I still did it and
it was my choice but this is something
that you're not gonna be able to do when
you're 48 really 50 years old what sixty
years old it's a shelf life that's what
it is you do this right now that you're
young you get as much as you can but
what's to say that if my daughter if
something happens tomorrow my daughter
like she's not gonna make money at forty
fifty sixty stripping about a girl I'd
be scared you know I'd be really scared
scared of what scared of her being taken
advantage of scared of her having bad
experiences that you've experienced
dancing you would probably have them
even whether or not you did dance
I was date raped when I was 18 my
coworker and I wasn't at a strip club
I'm not saying it can't happen just
because you're not a stripper I can't
get raped I'm just saying that you come
across and put yourself in a lot more
you know difficult positions being a
stripper I would imagine being a woman
from what I've heard from other girls
you don't think so so her point I had
the complete opposite of bringing I come
from I'm third generation college I had
a great middle-class upbringing I'm in
the situation situation I'm in because I
put myself in that situation and I made
the adult choice to dance however I'm
not saying if my child shows to dance
just like my mom I would demonize them
or love them any less I just would want
more for them but if they support them
is the question yes yes my mother
supports me would she rather me not be a
stripper of course I think that it takes
like a strong person to be an
entertainer or a sex worker on any level
and if
I had a child that grew up to be any of
those things and if it wasn't right for
them or if they felt like it was too
much for them I would hope they would
recognize it and get out of it because
I've seen girls kind of be like
emotionally crippled by this job and
that's really hard to see you know
because it's not made for everybody I
would just hope that my kid would be
aware enough to be like this sucks for
me it's strictly because I made decent
money that's just the bottom line I mean
do have I had really fun times at work
yeah I've had some great times at work
but at a point in time it just starts to
wear on you like I said the late nights
there are just certain things and
aspects about being in the club it just
really can wear on you over time and so
yeah it's definitely the money there's
times where like it's real dead at the
club and you have to go up and you make
like 2 bucks you're like damn that was
brutal but you still had fun like
looking at the ceiling mirrors laying
there doing nothing I mean what man
wouldn't want to go you know to a party
that's there's only woman it's right and
you're on number 20 to one and you got
to take your clothes off like it's gonna
sound pretty it's fun it's fun it's fun
like it
[Music]
strongly agree baby stripping is the
best you get people's money you stand
over a sea of dudes and then their
wallets fly towards you
it's amazing until you had like money
just fall over you it's like an
adrenaline you can't get from I mean
maybe lighting by skydiving or jumping
off of that feeling feels like yes
you're like oh yes I can pay this bill
tomorrow when I'm on stage doing you
know show do it I'll act pulled the
g-string off so bad just hearing woman
scream at the top of their lungs not
because somebody told them hey make some
noise but just because they couldn't
control himself enough and they just
like just had to scream they just had to
just let it out and I hear all of them
do at the same time that's very
empowering I mean being able to make
your own decision about your body that's
the number one when it comes to
feminists and being like you're not
empowered doing this it's like I made
the decision to be here nobody's making
this isn't for me it's my body and my
choice and that's empowerment
[Applause]
okay so that episode totally had me
rethinking my career choices I was
obsessed with that I think we hit on so
many different topics like it was so
much fun
it's like such a great cast oversized
but like we just love talking people and
we love talking to you guys and we love
hearing from you guys so leave us a
comment below about what you thought
about this episode also send us a DM on
Instagram but you have to be following
us and as always we'll see you next time
okay